[Music]
[Music]
hey there it's maud garrett and welcome
to an exciting new episode of rt
essentials now before we begin i have an
important question for you do you like
scary movies do you like bad
impersonations
what about rule breaking slashes that
reshaped the horror landscape this is an
easy question because you don't like
them you love them and today is your
lucky day because we are discussing the
film that awakened a sleeping genre and
spawned a franchise that includes four
feature-length installments a tv series
and an upcoming re-launch set for
release on january 14. that's right this
is the history of scream you instantly
pictured the ghost face mask didn't you
i know
maybe you thought of the iconic opening
sequence in the first film where drew
barrymore finds herself on the receiving
end of a deadly prank call aspiring
filmmakers take note as this scene not
only sets the tone for the entire
franchise but serves as a suspense
building masterclass before we dig in
though beware there will be spoilers so
if you haven't seen the films
then we should have a slumber party
scream
dude look behind you
look behind you turn around
behind you
i'll turn up
behind you
[Music]
scream was released on december 20th
1996 at a time when the slasher genre
was riddled with directed video features
and lackluster sequels i mean john
carpenter's halloween was already on its
fifth installment and nightmare on elm
street was on its sixth so needless to
say it was time to shake things up and
here's where screenwriter kevin
williamson enters frame you've probably
heard of his creations dawson's creek
the vampire diaries and the following
but prior to scream williamson was just
a fledgling writer in need of a
compelling story and a stroke of luck
the turning point would occur on march 9
1994 when a news magazine called turning
point
aired an episode on serial killer danny
rowling rowling had viciously murdered
five college students in gainesville
florida back in 1990 and was now facing
the death penalty williamson deeply
inspired by this episode birth to script
entitled scary movie the plot follows a
young group of students well-versed in
classic horror films whose small town is
shaken up by a sudden string of murders
at the hands of a masked assailant aka
ghostface though williamson took
inspiration from rowling's murders it's
important to note how unique his overall
concept was by having his characters
openly discuss and play out horror film
tropes he avoided being cliche himself
and created a meta genre-bending
statement unlike anything that had been
seen before lose the outfit if sydney
says it she'll flip
oh you want to play psycho killer
can i be the helpless victim
okay let's see
no please don't kill me mr ghostface i
want to be in the sequel in june of 1995
scary movie went on sale and immediately
sparked a bidding war between universal
pictures paramount pictures morgan creek
productions and several other giants as
the price of the script increased
studios began to drop out and the bid
was now between notorious director
oliver stone working under synergy
pictures and dimension films who at the
time was part of miramax i can't even
imagine what screen might have looked
like with stone directing but i guess
we'll never know because williamson
trusted that dimension would stay true
to the script and not censor the more
violent aspects so he agreed to their
offer of 400 000 and a guarantee of two
sequels now for an unknown rider this
deal was a magnitude that was unheard of
which is a testament to williamson's
craft and the foreseen potential of
scary movie next order of business find
a director but not just any director
someone terrifying a master of horror
and suspense someone who could hatch a
villain that forever haunts the masses
the obvious choice of course
rob reiner i am kidding he's a great
director though clearly wes craven was
the right man for the job i mean the guy
created freddy krueger what more do you
need to know so just like that craven
signed on movie got made and it was all
smooth sailing of course off into the
sunset roll and credits
not quite craven had no interest in
scary movie as he was actively trying to
distance himself from the horror genre
that he'd become synonymous with in fact
he passed on this project several times
and directors danny boyle george romero
sam raimi and robert rodriguez were all
considered jesus christ you don't know
the rules
have an aneurysm why don't you there are
certain rules that one must abide by in
order to successfully survive a horror
movie for instance
number one you can never have sex
williamson feared that these other
directors would over emphasize the
comedic elements and ultimately missed
the mark so he held out now when drew
barrymore read the script she demanded a
role in the film which nobody protested
since she was a rising star at the time
and as luck would have it craven's
current project had fallen apart so the
director now had an opening in his
schedule with barrymore attached and
this sudden window of free time craven's
producing partner marianne madeleine
felt that scary movie was too good to
pass up so she nudged the director and
after much reconsideration he finally
accepted the job instead of taking the
traditional horror film approach of
casting no names in the leading roles
scary movie chose actors that were
either well established or up and coming
barrymore was originally slated to play
the lead role of sydney prescott but had
unexpected commitments arise so she
instead took the smaller role of casey
becker who's killed off at the very
beginning of the film this was a bold
risk to take but it ended up paying off
by adding to the shock value of the
movie i mean wow if they're taking out
barrymore in the first five minutes what
else is going to happen
you get the idea
name the killer in friday the 13th jason
jason jason i'm sorry
that's the wrong answer
no it's not no it's not it was jason i'm
afraid not no way
listen it was jason i saw that movie 20
goddamn time then you should know
jason's mother mrs boris was the
original killer jason didn't show up
until the sequel i'm afraid that was a
wrong answer you tricked me the rest of
the cast was soon assembled with
courtney cox rose mcgowan skeet ulrich
david arquette matthew lillard and jamie
kennedy all on board and let's not
forget the voice of ghostface portrayed
by roger l jackson a crucial element in
the film's spooky style with the
ensemble cast locked in and a budget of
15 million dollars principal photography
began in april of 1996 and lasted for
just eight weeks shooting took place in
sonoma county california after craven
almost got fired by dimension for
insisting that they shoot in america and
not vancouver can you believe after all
that effort to finally get craven they
almost fired him before shooting
now i'm sure you're probably wondering
how scary movie came to be called scream
it is pretty simple as production was
nearing the finish line dimension
decided that the title scary movie
failed to convey the more satirical
elements of the film and felt that
scream was just a better fit
of course williamson and craven both
hated the change at first but they
eventually came around to it plus it
left the title open for the wayne's
brothers film that directly parodies
scream a movie making fun of a movie
that makes fun of movies ugh i love film
[Music]
demo
would you call me
and this pretty much brings us to the
release give or take a few lawsuits a
fire dp a mob of angry parents
petitioning to stop production 50
gallons of fake blood and a tedious
battle with the motion picture
association of america to drop the film
from an nc-17 rating aka box off a
suicide to an r rating who you still
with me neither am i great because this
journey was not done in vain no no
screen became the highest grossing
slasher film in history and overall
earned over 173
million dollars at the box office the
los angeles times called it a brevora
provocative send-up of horror pictures
roger ebert gave the film three out of
four stars and newsweek wrote that it
put some fun back into a very tired
genre in addition scream won saturn
awards for best actress nev campbell
best writing for williamson and best
horror film the movie's legacy is also
apparent in similar releases like i know
what you did last summer urban legend
and cherry falls all of which hoped to
piggyback off the commercial success of
scream
scream too
hello
hello sydney
remember me
what do you
want it's show time
then why don't you show your face you
[ __ ] coward
my pleasure
on december 12 1997 less than a year
later scream 2 was released in the u.s
hollywood's new favorite final girl
sydney prescott was back as was
ghostface and the rest of the cast minus
ulrich and lillard seeing as though they
met their demise in the first film after
sharing ghostface duties oh and
mcgowan's character tatum riley didn't
make the cut either despite begging mr
ghostface not to kill her so that she
could be in the sequel oh damn you
ghostface subsequently new villains were
in order so timothy oliphant was cast as
antagonist michie altieri and laurie
metcalf was cast as mrs loomis the
mother of ulrich's character billy who
is now seeking revenge for the murder of
her son news flash mrs loomis your son
billy was a diet johnny depp psychotic
killer who are you kidding we can't
argue with unconditional love or how
much uric wanted to be johnny depp in
that film
look at him actually it's partially why
he was cast a little nod to dep's role
in nightmare on elm street
[Applause]
going back to the conception of scream 2
we know that williamson had already
signed on for sequels with dimension and
that craven would be the obvious choice
to direct again if there'd been any
doubts about proceeding with these
follow-up films the box office
successive scream one put those doubts
to rest production was green lit in
march of 1997 with a budget of 24
million dollars 9 million more than the
first film so let's recap we got the
cast we got williamson we got craven we
got the budget we all love the title now
producers are happy what could possibly
go wrong better question what would a
screen production be without a splash of
drama or in this case instead of a
splash it's a leak the kind of leak that
plumbers lose sleep over the one leak to
rule them all the big reveal
yup williamson's script was leaked
during a transfer right there on the
internet for all to see was the plot the
dialogue and worst of all the identities
of the new killers who wants to watch a
murder mystery without the mystery so it
was back to the drawing board for
williamson who rewrote the plot changed
the film's finale and additionally
reshaped several of the characters roles
see that's what billy was good at he
knew
it's all about
execution
yeah
weren't forgetting one thing about billy
loomis
what's that
to prevent this from happening again
many of the actors themselves were kept
in the dark about the new big reveal and
information was given out on a strictly
need to know basis in light of this
mishap the swift production turn around
and competitive blockbusters like
titanic being released around the same
time it was a miracle that scream 2
wasn't a box office disaster actually it
set the december opening weekend record
and went on to gross 172.4
million worldwide just shy of the gross
for scream one and unlike most sequels
this one received generally positive
reviews with many believing that it
exceeded the high bar set fight's
predecessor scream three if you find
yourself dealing with an unexpected
backstory and a preponderance of
exposition then the secret rules do not
apply because you are not dealing with a
sequel you are dealing with the
concluding chapter
of a trilogy
that's right it's a rarity in the horror
field but it does exist following the
successive scream williamson was now a
major player in hollywood he'd already
written and released the first i know
you did last summer created the hit tv
series dawson's creek developed another
series called wasteland and was
directing the film teaching mrs tingle
which he'd written prior to screen one
this meant that there was no time to
fulfill his obligation of writing a
third screen installment although he had
written a treatment years before when he
first pitched the films as a potential
franchise dimension decided to replace
williamson with screenwriter aaron
kruger yeah that's his real last name
ah i love the horror space krueger was
given williamson's original treatment
and notes but mostly ignored them in
part for artistic reasons but mainly
because of the complicated environment
surrounding violent films and media at
the time it was in 1999 that the
horrific events at columbine high school
had occurred so a slasher film that
featured adolescent victims was just not
what the public wanted to see plus the
first screen films were already wrapped
up in controversy after being blamed for
several real-life copycat murders to
avoid negative attention krueger instead
focused more on satire and significantly
dialed back the brutality though craven
fought to keep things slashy for scream
3 most the cast returned yet again with
some much welcomed additions like parker
posey and patrick dempsey aka mcdreamy
interior jennifer's house living room
night the script page oh what's it say
the bodyguard stabbed to death the five
stand trapped he's rewriting the movie
the killer waits outside suddenly the
fax machine sends news to their face
it's attracting everybody outside the
film was set in hollywood where stab 3
is being shot now stab 3 is a film
that's based on the ghost face murders
in the first and second screams in
scream 3 cast members of stab 3 and the
survivors from the first films are
targeted and once again a killing spree
ensues
confusing i know let's clarify stab 3 is
a fictional film within a real film
about murders that take place in a film
that's based on real murders but uses
horror film tropes and the cast members
in stab 3 are getting murdered in the
film but also in real life
i somehow made it worse
my bad scream 3 was released on february
4 2000 and went on to gross 161.8
million dollars on a budget of 40
million
though it was still considered a
commercial success it underperformed to
the previous two films but that can
partially be talked up to the public's
attitude towards violent movies at the
time critics weren't as accepting of
this third installment with roger ebert
calling the characters so thin they're
transparent that's such a good burn
what do you expect though it's the third
movie in a slasher franchise films in
that category aren't going to be winning
the oscar for best picture anytime soon
scream four
[Music]
about a decade later the band got back
together for scream four craven
directing and williamson riding the way
it was meant to be the franchise was
originally supposed to end after three
films but the creators felt that there
was just more story to be told and fans
couldn't get enough of ghostface also
the scream brand had proven to be a cash
cow which probably factored into this
decision in just a little bit hollywood
it's called show business for a reason
people campbell cox and arquette
returned slightly older and wiser with
new additions emma roberts allison brie
hayden pineterry anthony anderson rory
culkin and adam brody the film starts
off at the 15th anniversary of the
woodsborough massacre that took place in
scream one and guess what there's a new
ghost face in town and he's killing high
school students again ah classic ghost
face sometimes you just have an itch you
can't stab
or can
and do sydney prescott returns to
woodsboro to promote her self-help book
as any final girl would do if they
managed to make it to film four sheriff
dewey has his hands full and his
reporter wife gail weathers is obviously
going to entangle herself in this new
wave of murders
[Applause]
still paranoid after the scream to leak
the actors in this film the real life
factors i mean were only given the first
75 pages of the 140 page script which
meant that even they didn't know the
true identity of ghostface until
probably until when he killed them
in the film not in real life just to
clarify who with a budget of 40 million
dollars the same as scream 3 shooting
began in june of 2010 and lasted just
over two months this was also the first
film in the series to rely on
computer-generated imagery switching out
the old collapsing knife trick for a
shiny new cgi blade screen 4 was
released on april 15 2011 and gross 97.2
million the lowest numbers for a screen
film but still a success overall critics
agreed that the film was a step up from
the previous installment with the
guardian calling it fun but more clever
clever than fiendishly ingenious sadly
wes craven passed away in august of
2015. this was the last film of his
prolific career which spanned over four
decades and left an indelible mark on
our culture a true master of horror
scream the tv series i don't forgive so
easily what did you do to him it's what
you're gonna do that's the real
i suggest you run
[Music]
dimension television and mtv production
development teamed up to produce scream
the tv series which originally aired on
mtv june 30th 2015. the show was first
developed by jill bloatvogel and
followed a string of murders that had
taken place in the fictional town of
lakewood it starred willa fitzgerald
john carner bex taylor laos and many
others this is probably a good time to
discuss the complicated history of the
ghostface mask as it was a source of
contention in the making of the series
the ghostface mask that we've all grown
to love and fear was actually created by
a new york-based company called fun
world back in 1991. craven and marianne
madeline happened to stumble upon the
mask while location scouting for the
first scream and they felt it was the
perfect costume for their slasher film
and when it comes to creating a villain
you just don't question craven
tyler
[Music]
[Music]
since fun world owned the design craven
and his effects team made various
attempts to copy the mask just enough to
emulate the expression without getting
sued after several sketches and molds it
was decided that nothing was suitable so
craven convinced the studio to license
the fun world mask for use in scream fun
fact because shooting had already
commenced there were a couple of scenes
where the mask is one of the alternate
moulds and not the fun world version but
aside from that ghostface's face stayed
true for the rest of the franchise that
is until the tv series decided to switch
things up by giving ghostface a new face
shape and expression this left audiences
feeling betrayed and craven himself
responded by saying sometimes you
realize something's not broken so don't
fix it that was the course we took on
all the scream films don't mess with
that it's just perfect the show ran for
three seasons 30 episodes and received
mixed reviews though season 2 was
considered a standout earning a tomato
meter score of 92
scream 2022
doors unlocked
and just like that we have made it to
2022 where a new scream is set for
release this fifth installment is
written by james vanderbilt and guy
busick and directed by matt bettinelli
alpen and tyler gillett who all worked
on 2019's ready or not which is a
fantastic comedy horror so the franchise
is in good hands especially with
williamson serving as executive producer
scream informally known as scream 5
stars our og faves campbell arquette cox
marley shelton and roger l jackson aka
ghost voice and brings on newcomers like
melissa barrera jenna ortega mason
gooding and jack quade hello
it's happening
three attacks so far do you have a gun
i'm sydney prescott of course i have a
gun
something about this one just feels
different
here's what we know so far 25 years have
passed since the original woodsborough
murders a new killer is going to emerge
he better be sporting the original
ghostface mask design and sydney
prescott will return to her hometown get
wrapped up in the new murders and have
to dig up her haunted past hey sydney
you should probably stop going back to
woodsbrook actually don't because we
want more movies screen 5 will hit
theaters on january 14th and is the
first scream film to not be directed by
craven one thing is for sure though it
will be a slasher's delight that we can
only hope would have made the late
director proud and there you have it the
long-winded frightfully frantic history
of scream appreciate you joining us here
on this ride and be sure to check out
the newest scream hitting theaters soon
heck go back and watch them all in
preparation and rank them on social
media i'm mod garrett appreciate you
tuning in more rt essentials are on the
way and remember there are certain rules
that one must abide by in order to
successfully survive a horror movie
[Music]
[Music]